veamos en donde estamos parados estamos
parados en el problema número 15 y el
problema número 15 está lleno de
triángulos así que déjenme tomar esta
herramienta para hacerte la figura que
está a continuación tenemos algo muy
parecido a esto y como por aquí y
después bajamos por acá tenemos algo así
y después tenemos algo por acá muy bien
y ahora tenemos otro triángulo a lo
primero tenemos esta altura que baja
a esta altura que está justo aquí no me
gustó
que está justo por aquí esta va a ser mi
altura y después tengo otro triángulo
porque tengo este triángulo que llega
hasta acá y después no llega hasta esta
esquina si no se detiene como por aquí
muy bien y este triángulo tiene varias
letras así que vamos a ponerlas en este
punto se llama q este punto se llama q
este de aquí se llama s este se llama
'the este se llama r y después tenemos
aquí a p
y aquí a b y además me dan este ángulo
este ángulo de 90 grados y me dan dos
datos muy importantes supongo que os
vamos a utilizar la relación entre u s /
/ v esto es lo mismo que un tercio un
tercio
qs / cube entre todo esto que tenemos
aquí es igual a un tercio y por otra
parte tengo que p
por ti / p por efe
esta relación es igual a tres cuartos
esto es igual a tres cuartos vamos a ver
a qué se refiere vete entre pr esto es
tres cuartos muy bien y lo que me
preguntan es lo siguiente cuál es el
área el área del triángulo del triángulo
pst pst en relación al área pst en
relación al área del triángulo grandote
del triángulo p q r
r es decir yo quiero saber a cuánto
equivale esta relación está división del
área del triángulo psc de este término
pequeño entre el triángulo p q r
muy bien ahora para resolver este
problema si me preguntan el área del
triángulo pst a quien es igual esto pues
vamos a ponerlo aquí el área el área del
triángulo pst p s t entonces quiero
saber cómo sacamos el área de este
triángulo y bueno nosotros sabemos que
el área del triángulo pst por las
fórmulas que hemos visto desde muy
chicos esto es lo mismo que un medio la
base por la altura es decir la base por
la altura entre dos un medio la base
pero en la base vale pp la base vale pp
y la altura vale sb por s b esto es lo
que vale el área del triángulo pst ahora
por otra parte también quiero saber el
área del triángulo
r el triángulo p q r y esto es igual a
un medio la base por la altura un medio
de hecho date cuenta que este es un
medio y esto en medio tarde o temprano
se van a cancelar un medio la base que
espere pr por la altura la altura escupe
por q ve muy bien es más vamos a ponerlo
con otro color
nuestro refiriendo a este triángulo
grandote que tenemos aquí el triángulo p
efe y después regresamos a p esta es
esta área muy bien ahora vamos a poner
esta división y que me va a quedar si yo
sustituyó literalmente me queda el área
del triángulo pst pues esto es un medio
un medio pt por sb es justo lo que tengo
aquí ya esto lo voy a dividir entre el
área del triángulo p q r y el área del
triángulo p q r es un medio
pr por q vez por cuba y aquí lo primero
que puedes ver es que este un medio y
este un medio se van uno que multiplica
y uno que dividen se van no los
necesitamos por ahora y nos quedamos
solamente con pt porque se ve entre pr
porque v
sin embargo por aquí necesitamos
utilizar estos datos y de hecho fíjate
que aquí tenemos pt / pr
aquí tenemos ptm / pr es decir que esta
parte de aquí esto es lo mismo por lo
que me dice la fórmula que tres cuartos
esto es lo mismo que tres cuartos por lo
tanto vamos a utilizarlo y en lugar de
estar jalando estas variables
voy a poner tres cuartos esto es lo
mismo que tres sobre cuatro y me quedan
sb entre cuba e se ven entre q b ahora
lo malo es que aquí tenemos q s entre v
igual a un tercio y aquí yo lo que
quiero saber es ese b entre cuba y bueno
estos dos en un principio parecen no
parecerse
vamos a ver si podemos utilizar un poco
la lógica qs entre coupé es un tercio
cum de aquí hasta acá q s esta relación
entre esta relación es igual a un tercio
date cuenta que si esta altura fuera 1
vamos a suponer que es un entero
entonces este pedacito es un tercio de
ese entero este pedacito es un tercio de
todo lo que me da esta altura porque eso
es lo que me dice la relación un tercio
qs entre coupé es igual a un tercio y si
todo esto fuera uno y aquí nos tomamos
un tercio de este pedazo entonces cuánto
debe de valer este pedazo pues bueno
este pedazo debe de valer dos tercios
los otros dos tercios que me faltan para
llegar a 1 es decir que si q s entre v
es un tercio
qs entre cube esto de aquí es igual a un
tercio por lo tanto ese b entre v
dos tercios vamos a apuntar lo aquí s pm
/ v esto tiene que ser igual a dos
tercios lo que me falta para llegar a
este entero o dicho de otra manera las
otras dos terceras partes de esta
longitud y ya está es justo lo que yo
quería
sb / cuba ahora ya sea que vale dos
tercios esto de aquí es lo mismo que
esto de acá y por lo tanto
sustituyéndolo me va a quedar que esto
es igual a tres cuartos por dos tercios
y esto es igual a éste con este se van
dos entre cuatro es un medio un medio es
la relación del área del triángulo pst
entre el área del triángulo pq el que es
justo lo que yo quería y por cierto date
cuenta que este problema lo único que
teníamos que hacer
eran poner aquí las dos áreas de una
forma explícita dividirlas ver que se
cancelaba en un medio ver esta relación
y después una de las partes más
importantes de este problema fue
observar la relación que
a de cv s / v con respecto a ese bebé
entre cuba y darnos cuenta que era lo
que faltaba para llegar al entero ya
está la respuesta es un medio y espero
que no te hayas confundido así que vamos
a hacer el siguiente ejercicio voy a
borrar el pizarrón espero que no estés
confundido y realmente espero que no
estés confundido porque ella de gracias
no es bueno para confundir a nadie pero
mejor vamos al siguiente problema que es
el problema de 16 y además es un
problema de funciones y los problemas de
funciones a mí en lo personal me gustan
mucho dice hdx hdx lo defino como 14 14
más x cuadrada sobre 4
y además yo sé que h de 2 m
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 9 m lo
que me preguntan es cuál puede ser uno
de los valores para m lo que me
preguntan es uno de los valores de m
y viendo esta función creo que vamos a
tener que utilizar una fórmula
cuadrática a ver veamos un poco hdx es
igual a 14 más x cuadrada entre 4
cuantos h de 12 m utilizando la
definición de la función h de 2 m esto
es exactamente igual que 14 + y en lugar
de x voy a poner 12 me voy a sustituir a
x por 12m y me quedan 2 m elevado al
cuadrado y esto dividido entre 4 bueno
esto es lo que sé que vale h 12 m
utilizando la definición de una función
sin embargo por otra parte me dan el
dato de que h de 12 m es igual a 9
m es decir que esto es lo mismo que 9 m
utilizando primero la definición de la
función y después utilizando el dato que
me dan y vamos a elevar esto al cuadrado
para ver cuánto es me va a quedar que
esto es lo mismo que 14 más 2 al
cuadrado es 4 en al cuadrado es m
cuadrada entre 4 y esto es igual a 9 m y
aquí 4.4 se puede ir está de lujo
entonces me queda que m cuadrada + 14
esto es igual a 9 ene y ahora qué te
parece si de aquí restó 9 m de ambos
lados de la ecuación voy a restar 9 m
para que me quede esta ecuación igual a
cero
estos dos se van me queda igual a cero y
del otro lado me queda encuadrada menos
9 m más 14 ahora aquí tenemos una
ecuación cuadrática y cuando tenemos una
ecuación cuadrática lo primero que se
nos viene a la mente es la ecuación
cuadrática
y creo que esta expresión es mucho más
fácil de factorizar date cuenta que si
buscamos dos números que su suma sea
menos 9 y su multiplicación sea 14 de
una manera fácil y sencilla podemos
pensar en menos 7 y menos 2 o sea que
esto es exactamente lo mismo que en
menos 7 que multiplica a su vez a m
menos 2 lo único que estoy haciendo es
factor izando esta expresión que tengo
aquí arriba si no recuerdas cómo llegué
de este paso a este paso entonces es de
suma importancia que revises cómo
factorizar de los vídeos de álgebra
sobre factorización porque esto es muy
importante que lo tengas muy a la mano
en todo el conocimiento de matemáticas
factorizar siempre ayuda bastante
entonces ya que tengo esta expresión que
aquí lo que yo estoy diciendo es que dos
números multiplicados son igual a cero
por lo tanto el primero 017 esto es
igual a cero o menos 2 esto es igual a
cero
o el otro muy bien y si m menos 7 fuera
0 entonces de aquí voy a obtener que m
es igual a 7 y si m menos 2 fuera igual
a 0 de que voy a obtener que m es igual
a 2 y ya está
m puede ser o 7 o 2 m puede ser 72 y es
justo lo que me preguntaban encuentra un
valor posible para m pues puede ser 7 o
puede ser 2 ya está así que este
ejercicio creo que estuvo muy fácil y
muy entretenido me gustan mucho los
ejercicios de funciones pero bueno creo
que se me ha acabado el tiempo me quedan
dos problemas y son perfectos para
verlos en el siguiente vídeo así que
mejor nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo no
te lo pierdas